savard et
sacré aux perspectives de long terme sur
l'énergie et le climat alors c'est un
petit peu fou de prétendre
imaginez prévoir ce qui va se passer
dans 20 ou 30 ans mais il faut parfois
être un petit peu un petit peu fou pour
pour savoir un peu on va utilisera ton
encore les énergies fossiles en 2040
2050 parviendra-t-on à faire beaucoup
d'économies d'énergie les pays émergents
vont ils eux aussi changer leurs
habitudes alors pour répondre à ces
questions
on va dire 3
personnes qui vont nous initier des
choses théorique et puis trois autres
plus pratique plus concrète dans la
première partie
patrick artus chef économiste de natixis
jean marc jancovici président de the
shift roger guesnerie professeur émérite
au collège de france
isabelle kocher directeur général d'
angie ont dit directeur général n'est
pas directrice c'est pas important
patrick pouyanné président directeur
général de total et david kimelfeld
présidente de la métropole de lyon on
démarre avec patrick artus merci jean
paul bonne après midi à tous je vais
plutôt poser des questions à quoi nos
différents invités et aussi bien
d'ailleurs sur des questions ce qu'est
ce que tu évoquais aussi bien sur les
points sur les points un peu théorique
que sur des points pour être concret est
en fait j'avais trois groupes de
questions
première question dans ce
mes camarades autotour reconnaîtront à
quelques questions plus tôt il devrait
répondre je pense à nous donc je vais
pas les adresser directement première
question quelle peut être la vitesse de
transition vers un modèle énergétique
appelons le vert alors vous avez tous vu
les travaux récents de l'onu on n'est
pas du tout aujourd'hui sur une
trajectoire compatible avec les accords
de paris de la cap 21
quand on fait les calculs et qui sont un
peu compliqué mais on arrive à trouver
que aujourd'hui le monde se situe sur
une trajectoire à 3° 7 donc
d'augmentation de la température fin du
siècle et pas deux ni encore moins
ennemis et ceci avec à la fois la
croissance du transport qui reste forte
la croissance des émergents des pays
comme l'inde ou la chine qui construit
continue oeuvre une croissance de leur
consommation d'énergie fossile très
rapide
si on devait aujourd'hui se placer sur
la trajectoire à 2 degrés il faudrait
que les émissions de co2 de la planète
diminue de pas tout à fait un an et demi
pour cent par an à partir du niveau nous
sommes aujourd'hui
or elles augmentent de 1 6% par an donc
on est trois points par an au dessus de
ce qui ferait de degrés donc à nouveau
on est c'est mes calculs sont justes à
3° 7 donc le premier groupe de questions
et de dire bon est-ce qu'il faut
extrapoler la situation présente est
donc est ce qu'on va finir à 4 degrés
d'augmentation de la température de la
planète avec les conséquences que vous
imaginez ou est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
une transition plus rapide qui serait
probablement une transition d'abord vers
le vers le gaz puis vers en même temps
vers les renouvelables
donc est-ce qu'on peut accélérer
la vitesse de transition et de
énergétique par rapport à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui comment est-ce qu'on traite
le problème des émergents par exemple de
l'inde qui utilisent toujours énormément
le charbon comme production comme source
de production d'électricité et qu'elle
est dans cette dans cette stratégie le
rôle du nucléaire alors ça c'est pas
plutôt pour mon voisin de gauche
est-ce qu'il faut complètement oublié le
nucléaire ou est-ce que leclerc garde un
rôle dans la transition vers un modèle
qu'ils soient plus économes en émissions
de carbone voilà à nouveau c'est très
impressionnant à de voir qu'on n'est pas
sont très robustes sur cette trajectoire
qui est à peu près à 4 degrés voyez
juste et je finis sur ce premier point
3.2 trop d'émissions de co2 par an si on
sent aucun progrès technologiques les
émissions de co2 ont une élasticité d'à
peu près 0,50 opib ce qui veut dire
qu'il faudrait toutes choses égales par
ailleurs réduire la croissance mondiale
d'un point et demi par an pour revenir
sur la trajectoire à 2 degrés donc on a
à peu près la taille de l'enjeu deuxième
groupe de questions quelles politiques
publiques
qu'est ce que peuvent faire les
politiques publiques aujourd'hui pour
améliorer cette perspective alors j'ai
l'impression mais roger sur manquer de
riz en parlera qu'il ya un très gros
consensus aussi bien chez les
industriels que sur les économistes pour
dire qu'il faudrait un prix mondial du
co2 mais la probabilité que nous ayons
appris mondial du co2 nous paraît assez
faible les différentes estimations
disent qu'il faudrait en gros que que le
prix du co2 soit de l'ordre de 30 à 40
euros la tonne pour générer les bonnes
incitations importe les bonnes décisions
soient prises le contrat sur deux se
promènent suivant les jours entre 5 et 6
euros donc aujourd'hui le co2 est
pratiquement gratuit 1
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
point important est qu'on en a parlé
avec roger à quelques jours il ya
énormément de réglementation dans le
domaine de l'énergie et du climat sur
les émissions des voitures elles et des
bateaux auraient une nouvelle règle mais
ces réglementations ne sont pas
soutenues par un prix du co2 ce qui veut
dire qu'elles peuvent partir dans toutes
les directions et en fait correspondent
chacune d'entre elles un prix implicite
du co2 qui est différent donc peut-être
est-ce qu'on met beaucoup d'argent pour
faire certains types d'économie à
certains endroits et pas assez à
d'autres si on avait l'impression et le
co2 va les 40 euros la tonne on aurait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
rationnelle ou le ciel le carbone aurait
le même prix partout
voilà donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
si on n'arrive pas à avoir une un accord
mondial sur le prix du co2 qui est
probable est ce que l'europe peut faire
elle même dans son coin un accord co2 et
taxer les co2 aux frontières ce qui est
une proposition qu'on a vue est ce que
ça marche est ce que c'est faisable
troisième sujet qui sont extrêmement
importants c'est des sujets
technologiques dont j'aimerais bien que
personne autour de moi peut-être
n'ouvrir vous donne un centre
d'information ou est-ce qu'on en ait des
progrès technologiques et il y aura son
nombre de questions qui sont assez
évidemment centrale la première question
énoncée celle du stockage de
l'électricité
vous savez que quand on passe aux
renouvelables on a ce qu'on appelle
l'intermittence attire qu'on produit
qu'une partie du temps il faut du soleil
ou du vent le en moyenne on compte que
une source d'énergie renouvelable
travail à pleine puissance à peu près
30% du temps et donc on a un problème de
stockage vous voyez sur 70% du temps et
si on n'arrive pas à régler le problème
de stockage
il est totalement illusoire évidemment
de penser qu'on pourra utiliser les
énergies renouvelables comme source
majeure d'approvisionnement énergétique
puisque je vais à nouveau aujourd'hui si
on a 36 on a six ont fait 102 capacité
renouvelables il faut y associer 300 du
notre capacité thermique à côté à cause
de l'intermittence alors est-ce qu'on a
des progrès perspectifs
sur sur le stockage aujourd'hui une des
formes les plus importantes de saucats
gens sur les batteries la technologie de
batterie la plus moderne millions on
arrive ici sans doute à une
impossibilité d'abord physique sûr qu'il
faut des batteries de plus en plus
grosse et pour stocker suffisamment
d'énergie pour faire des batteries
lithium-ion il faut du cobalt du lithium
et des terres rares et on en a des
ressources limitées
en plus avec des endroits très bizarre
un dieu doc des idéologies car le cobalt
est presque entièrement république
démocratique du congo et le lithium en
chine et au chili
ils étaient rares sont à 90% en chine
donc sacré une rareté en même temps une
dépendance grande vis-à-vis d'un petit
nombre de producteurs donc est-ce que ce
qu'on aurait ce qu'on fera des progrès
dans le stockage et fera d'autres
batteries et d'autres technologies
il ya la question de l'hydrogène est ce
qu'on peut penser que c'est la bonne
source de stockage est ce qu'on va
rendre cette la production d'hydrogène
plus efficace voilà ton choix que cette
question d'interruption c'est du
stockage et centrale parce que ce que
vous dites à 20 ou 30 ans ne peut pas
être le même suivant que vous croyez
qu'on arrivera à stocker que vous n'y
croyez pas deux points pour terminer
est ce que est ce qu'on fait bien tous
les calculs correctement quand on évalue
les effets environnementaux telle ou
telle innovation technique et je
prendrai un exemple qui suit la voiture
électrique
les voitures électriques sont
considérées comme un progrès c est ce
que c'est tout à fait certain est ce
qu'on regarde toute la chaîne de
production démantèlement des batteries
précisément il reste est ce qu'on
regarde l'origine de l'électricité et
donc est ce qu on fait toujours les ford
avoir une vision scientifique intégrée
complète de menton quand on regarde une
nouvelle technologie de son effet global
sur l'environnement et bien sûr on voit
dans le cas d'un moteur électrique que
probablement on peut régler le problème
de pollution urbaine mais pas
probablement le problème de ces auteurs
en tout cas pour l'instant
donc voilà donc trois groupes deux
questions est-ce qu'on est condamné à
rester sur la trajectoire à 4 degrés
est-ce qu'on saurait mettre au moins en
europe en place des politiques
incitatives qui soit correcte et qu'elle
est quel est l'état de la réflexion dans
l'industrie / sur les problèmes
technologiques les plus sévères merci
jean marc jancovici
mais c'est bien le micro est censé
passer comme ça bon on a quatre minutes
trente pour répondre à tout ça je pense
que je veux oui absolument
dans dans mes modestes aux activités
j'en ai une qui est d'être enseignant
donc je fais un cours à paris je suis
désolé par lyon pour des élèves
ingénieurs ça fait vingt-quatre heures
et en 24 heures j'arrive à décortiquer
un peu 10% des questions qu'il ya d'être
posée donc donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
que ça veut juste dire que pour rentrer
dans ce genre de sujet malheureusement
en une heure on va se livrer à quelques
échanges d'avis et ça ira pas beaucoup
plus loin que ça je vais faire un juste
une fin je répondre à aucune des
questions et répondra tout en disant que
dans ce genre d'exercice prospectifs en
fait il ya une première grille de
lecture qui est extrêmement utile qui
est de séparer ce qui dépend de nous de
ce qui est de ceux qui par dont ne
dépend pas de nous le
lithium compte trois proton et dans 50
ans il comptera toujours 3 proton et il
ya 50 ans il comptait déjà trois bretons
et ça changera pas le diamètre de la
terre il est ce qu'il est à peu près 13
mille kilomètres et il n'est pas près de
changer dans les 50 ans qui viennent
donc il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
comme ça alors ça peut paraître des
banalités ce que je dis mais qui ne
changeront pas et alors dans les deux
trucs majeure qui ne changeront pas dans
les 50 ans qui viennent y est la loi de
conservation de l'énergie et avec 2 3 et
on se rend compte quand on aborde ce
genre de problème que si on se contente
d'utiliser à son profit la loi de
conservation d'énergie et avec 2 3 on
est déjà capable de faire un tri
extrêmement fort entre les diverses
options qui s'offrent à nous et très
souvent le résultat de ce tri il a une
valeur d' usage qui est faible non pas
parce que le calcul est pas bon mais
parce qu'on vient heurter tout un tas de
propos qui ont été affirmés 352 x et à
force d'entendre 352 font un truc ça
devienne vérité on se pose plus à ce
moment la question oui juste pour ceux
qui comme moi ne savent pas ce que c'est
que la loi de conservation de l'énergie
un petit rappel c'est une race et
ennuyeux vous sachiez pas ça puisque
hier soir vous étiez au 20 heures de
france 2 non c'est pas bon c'est pas
tout et la loi de conservation du reste
au 20 heures de france 2 j'ai noté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt que en trois minutes
d'autant on a déploré que les affaires
d'un parapétrolier aille plus mal pour
juste derrière le sujet d'après déploré
qu' on ne fasse pas de progrès sur la
question climatique
juste après
donc
j'ai bien fait de venir voilà et justin
a fait on s'est félicité du fait que la
population alors sur une planète qui
fait toujours 13 mille kilomètres je
sais pas si c'était le but donc le la
loi de conservation de l'énergie a dit
un truc très simple elle dit que dans un
système clos l'énergie se conserve et de
là vous tirer une conclusion absolument
majeur qui est que toutes énergies
utilisées par les hommes ne peut être
que extraites de l'environnement on ne
peut rien faire d'autre qu'extraire à
notre profit une énergie qui existe déjà
dans l'environnement parce que si on
était capable de faire autrement on
s'appellerait merlin l'enchanteur
ce qui n'est pas le cas et ça veut dire
par exemple que dans les énergies qui
ont été évoqués par patrick par exemple
hydrogène ya pas d hydrogène natif sur
terre enfin quantité ridicule et donc il
faut le faire avec autre chose on peut
on sait très bien le faire et
industriels air liquide deux premiers
qui s'est extrêmement bien faire ça mais
il faut le faire avec autre chose donc à
ce moment il faut avoir une analyse en
chaîne de valeur en cycle de vie pour
savoir quel est le bilan global de toute
cette affaire et extraire de l'énergie à
notre profit c'est quelque chose qui est
d'autant plus facile que la source est
concentré et pas trop difficile d'accès
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pétrole de notre ami puyané est la reine
des énergies parce que mère nature a
concentré cette énergie en quelques
dizaines ou centaines de millions
d'années avec un rendement soit dit en
passant qui est totalement ridicule lors
de 10 - 12 et il y à kara littéralement
se baisser pour le ramasser
c'est la raison pour laquelle le coût
technique d'extraction d'un baril dans
le désert saoudien
tant que les saoudiens nous laisse le
faire c'est de l'ordre d'une fraction de
centimes par kilowattheure est à ce prix
là une fraction de centimes par
kilowattheure est à ce prix là vous avez
déjà la fonction de stock dire que votre
pétrole où l'avaient extrait vous vous
en servez exactement quand vous voulez
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
problème c'est la raison pour laquelle
on est passé des énergies renouvelables
qui étaient les seules énergies que nous
utilisions il ya deux siècles
il ya deux siècles humanité 700% venir
donc pour répondre à la question de
patrick est ce que c'est possible oui
c'est possible
physiquement c'est possible on a déjà
fait le reste
est ce que c'est le confort de vie
d'aujourd'hui jamais de la vie mais est
ce que c'est possible oui donc le on est
passé de ces énergies très diffuse donc
demandant beaucoup d'efforts pour être
extraites de l'environnement le vent le
soleil etc permettant des usages
intermittents donc la marine à voile ça
arrive et quand ça arrive et puis quand
ça arrive et pas assez vite les marins
avaient scorbut à des usages qui
aujourd'hui sont totalement pilotable
est totalement piloter et c'est ça qui
fait qu'on est capable d'organiser la
société avec des trains qui partent à
l'heure quelles que soient les
conditions climatiques
donc le l'exercice auquel je vous invite
sans répondre précisément à aucune des
questions on y reviendra totalement mais
on peut après un inventaire fastidieux à
la prévert c'est juste de dire que quand
on raisonne avec quelques faits enfin
apprendre à quelques règles simples
je le redis des calculs d'or de grandeur
je vous en donner un juste après la loi
de conservation de l'énergie l'énergie
doit bien sortir de quelque part plus
est les diffuse plus elle est coûteuse
et c'est pas une question de taille de
réservoir c'est une question de capacité
de facilité à l'extraire de
l'environnement et une fois que vous
avez ces grandes règles
vous êtes capable globalement de
commencer à vous y retrouver un peu dans
toute cette affaire pour l'électricité
et voiture électrique c'est pareil
l'électricité il y en a pas dans la
nature
sauf à brancher directement les voitures
sur les éclairs d'orage ce qu'on ne sait
pas faire pour le moment
et donc on l'a fait avec autre chose et
donc l'électricité est une aussi bonne
manière que la façon de la produire et
d'une aussi bonne idée par donc la façon
de la produire pas mieux est pas moins
bien
alors un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur juste pour finir là-dessus je
me suis amusé c'est un truc que je viens
de mettre en ligne sur mon site à faire
une comparaison des capitaux qui sont
nécessaires pour fournir l'électricité
un pays comme la france mais en fait ce
n'est pas une affaire de quantité j'ai
fait une comparaison entre si on a le
système actuel que je qualifie en
première approximation de tout nucléaire
et si on a un système qui est basé
totalement sûre d énergie que sont
l'éolien ou le solaire qui sont pas
toutes les nerfs parce que
l'hydroélectricité qui est la première
électricité d'origine renouvelable dans
le monde s'est fortement développé parce
que comme le pétrole c'est une énergie
concentrée les vallées d'altitude
permettre de concentrer l'eau et donc on
retombe sur quelque chose de concentré
pilotable et ça c'est qu'on sait
concurrentiel avec les énergies fossiles
mais si je prends que l'éolien ou du
solaire vous avez un rapport en gros
d'un facteur 10 entre donc il faut
investir dix fois plus d'argent pour
avoir un système qui est 100% éolien
plus stockage ou 100% sur barrage
réversible un pas sur batterie parce que
si c'est sur batterie vous rajoutez
plutôt un facteur 50
donc ce genre de raisonnement
ça vous permet de faire le tri très très
vite contre une politique publique qui a
une chance d'arriver à ses fins et une
politique publique pour laquelle vous
pouvez parier toutes vos économies sur
le fait qu'on n'y arrivera jamais ce qui
peut avoir un intérêt pour votre
patrimoine propre
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
roger oui merci donc le titre indique
qu'un endroit c'était s'intéresser à
l'énergie au climat moi je masse mais
connaissant sont surtout sur la
politique climatique à j'ai écrit un
rapport pour le conseil d'analysé
économique vers 2003 qui s'appelle kyoto
et comme il est fait de serre dont je ne
peux pas oublier que j'ai présenté la
première version à lionel jospin la
seconde version à jean pierre raffarin
c'est des choses qui s'oublie pas j'ai
créé pas mal sur des choses plus ou
moins abstraites sur les questions de
politique climatique est un livre grand
public dans lequel pour lequel je me
permets de faire de la publicité ici
c'est bien l'occasion qui s'appelle deux
économistes enjeux climatiques que j'ai
écrit avec laure stern pour ce qu'ils
connaissent bien mixte heures entendu
parler mais je dois dire que sur les
questions énergétiques je suis un
béotien
j'ai regardé des articles sur le
l'évolution de la production
d'électricité pendant 21e siècle mais
c'est beaucoup trop abstrait et une fois
au moins deux heures pour les proprement
parler par contre j'ai des connaissances
simplement de seconde main il faut que
j'ai à vous sur l'état et les
perspectives de la recherche sur les
renouvelables sur les problèmes de
l'équipe du mix de production électrique
donc du système de distribution lorsque
vous avez des sources d'énergie
différente et je suis aussi un peu
ignorant des discussions européennes sur
le paquet énergie propre qui se déroule
actuellement qui est préparé par les
commissions alors là j'ai une excuse
parce que les propositions de la
commission atteignent environ 1000 pages
et ça fait beaucoup malgré tout que j'ai
pas le temps de lire avant de venir ici
alors je vais simplement pour garder mon
à casquette d'économistes je suis
économiste et qu'est ce que je vais dire
je vais dire d'abord que une politique
climatique qui a qui consiste à stopper
les émissions décarbonés se déclinent
largement politique énergétique et je
vais évoquer ce que sont les l'idéal ou
le fantasme des économistes est une
bonne politique climatique devrait faire
émerger un prix du carbone dans l'espace
considéré dans l'espace cette politique
climatique c'est parce qu'aussi rsa peut
être le nom d' c'était l'objectif de
kyoto faire les maires j'ai un prix du
carbone mondial
ça peut être l'europe on peut essayer de
faire émerger un prix du carbone en
europe et c est naturellement une très
bonne politique climatique doit faire
émerger un prix du carbone mais aussi
des perspectives plausible de
l'évolution de ce prix du carbone
perspective associée aux contraintes
quantitative aux objectifs quantitatifs
de cette politique climatique
alors comment y parvenir salon c'est
qu'on sait pas très bien y parvenir on
sait pas très bien
lorsque j'ai envisagé d'être dictateur
mondiale j'avais donné ma solution mais
je n'ai pas été suivi
je crains que que les
les essais d'autres dictateurs se soit
voix au même sort je plaisante
évidemment
alors pourquoi une politique climatique
pourquoi un prix du carbone est une
bonne chose pour une politique
énergétique parce qu'il fournit un bon
signal pour la réduction des émissions
par les émetteurs il fait n'est donc un
bon signal pour le bénéfice d'une
innovation et donc il fournit une
incitation appropriée à investir à
emprunter pour investir et c'est
naturellement les sit in à citation qui
est plutôt plus raisonnable que celles
fournies par les subventions quelque peu
arbitraire
quelques noms les pratiques aujourd'hui
alors naturellement ça veut pas dire que
c'est parce qu'on avait une bonne
politique climatique on avait un bon
prix du carbone tout se passerait bien
naturellement tout dépend naturellement
de la qualité du signal
la qualité des anticipations de prix et
la qualité du la dynamique interne de
l'innovation
par ailleurs ça ne résoudrait absolument
pas tous les problèmes
la rentabilité d'innovation dépens et de
tel ou tel secteur de renouvelables
dépend du coût du stockage comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure ça résout pas le
problème de la place du nucléaire le
poids relatif que vous mettez au risque
nucléaire par rapport aux risques
climatiques qui découlent de kiki qui
détermine votre position sur nucléaire
alors sans prix du carbone pourquoi
c'est gênant bien parce que vous avez
diverses dimensions de la politique
énergétique je vais prendre la prônent
la sécurité d'approvisionnement le
problème de l'intégration des marchés
le problème de l'efficacité énergétique
le problème de la
réduction des consommations de ddb
d'essence par les voitures
tous ces problèmes sont des chapitres
d'une la politique énergétique dans
lequel la discussion
si on dispose un prix du carbone
extrêmement simplifier et clarifier dans
lequel sinon il ya le risque que ces
centres et du carbone c'est qu'il ya une
dispersion considérable des prix
implicite du carbone selon les chapitres
donc une forme de gaspillage des
ressources donc la recommandation de ce
point de vue c'est que pour chaque
mesure touchant la politique climatique
dans un monde où on n'a pas de prix du
carbone il faut il faut il faut essayer
de faire évaluer le coût implicite du
carbone qui justifie cette politique
je crois que ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'être important alors maintenant
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
europe
alors est-ce qu'on a un prix du carbone
en europe on a on a un marché qui
s'appelle le european trading skim qui
fait émerger un prix du carbone
mais ce prix du carbone non seulement
n'est pas du tout son bon niveau
on peut essayer de discuter pourquoi
j'ai écrit des articles 10 ans si on
d'analysé et donc il est pas au lieu
d'être
les contre productif parce qu'il
introduit des bruits dans les décisions
dans le 2 sur la politique énergétique
dans les divers domaines de la politique
énergétique qui sont qui sont inutiles
alors est-ce que qu'est ce que devrait
faire l'europe l'europe elle devrait
j'ai encore une minute trente secondes
30 secondes mais vous aurez le temps de
revenir sur ces thèmes-là au fur et à
mesure de la discussion et puis pour
répondre aux questions de la salle
oui donc alors l'europe comme l'a dit
comme l'annoncé patrie toute valeur
pourrait faire malgré tout en l'absence
d'un prix mondial du carbone dans un
accord de type kyoto
on pourrait imaginer une taxe carbone
européenne taxe carbone européenne avec
pourquoi pas justement frontières autres
grands chapitres sur lequel il faudrait
plus de 24 heures pour discuter et mais
dans l'état actuel des choses en
l'absence de ce prix du carbone européen
des contenus des interférences entre le
prix du marché au ts des subventions
accordées aux renouvelables qui
utilisent le système de prix d'une
certaine manière mais de façon non
coordonnées je crois que ça se passera
très bien et que l'on est dans une
situation de faire une politique de
l'énergie dans un environnement un peu
kafkaïen
voilà merci alors on a entendu les
économistes maintenant les acteurs de
ces marchés de l'énergie d'abord
isabelle kocher
merci jean paul en moi je m'escrime si
je comprends bien au titre de deux
praticiennes de l'énergie comme comme
vous avez dit tout à l'heure et donc
avec beaucoup d'humilité parce que c'est
une réalité qui est cette force elle
transition énergétique elle et elle est
à la fois elle est porteuse d'espoir je
crois je crois vraiment et en même temps
elle est super exigeantes en termes de
de pilotage pour pour tout le monde je
pense à la fois pour les régulateurs ça
a été largement évoquée mais aussi pour
les acteurs industriels ppi pour pour
nous tous qui sommes tous aussi des
consommateurs de l'énergie et donc des
actes il avait beaucoup été question là
je trouve de technologie moi je vais
revenir un tout petit cran en amont je
pense que ça n'est pas d'abord un sujet
technologique en réalité c'est à dire
que c'est de mon point de vue c'est
d'abord un changement de mentalité alors
on peut discuter la manière dont il est
dont il est advenu moi je pense que le
réchauffement climatique problématique
globale s'il en est absolument globale
et ses preuves
première fois sans doute confus que
l'humanité fait face à quelque chose qui
est aussi globale que ce sujet là avec
un réservoir de co2 en circulation qui
est totalement fongible probablement
joué un rôle majeur dans sedan se
réveille là mais toujours est il que moi
j'ai le sentiment que le monde a changé
de lunettes et c'est d'abord ça qui
s'est passé et ceci a généré des
politiques publiques de subventions
massives et
et ça a démarré en europe d'ailleurs
mais c'est d'abord ça puisque me
souviens bien qu'à l'époque quand quand
ce mouvement a démarré les technologies
renouvelables dont on parle aujourd'hui
elle était absolument hors d'atteinte en
termes économiques s'étaient exorbitants
je me souviens des premiers tarifs de
rachat de l'électricité produite à
partir d'énergie solaire 700 euros du
mégawattheures donc mais c'était s'était
même si vous n'êtes pas très familier
des prix de l'énergie vous vous rendez
bien compte que c'est extrêmement
c'était extrêmement cher est totalement
non économique donc c'est d'abord une
volonté politique et cette volonté
politique elle se nourrissait de quelque
chose qui est un mouvement profond de
population je crois que c'est c'est
d'abord ça qui c'est qui s'est passé
alors depuis les progrès ont été
spectaculaires 700 euros du
mégawattheures c'était en 2008 si je me
souviens bien on est moins de dix ans
plus tard et nous nous devons de
répondre à des appels d'offres en
dessous de 20 euros du mégawattheure on
est content du de l'énorme bascule on
n'est pas du tout dans des progrès
incrémentaux là en étant des choses qui
sont assez spectaculaires
alors je vous dis je triche un peu 700
euros du mégawattheures c'était en
france 20 euros du mégawattheures
c'était au moyen-orient mais mais quand
même retenu que tout ça ça évolue très
très très vite et ça continue l'énergie
à partir de solaire donc je crois que
premièrement c'est porteur de beaucoup
de progrès disons le ensuite il ya plein
de sujets à régler qu'ils ne sont pas
encore pourquoi ces porteurs de progrès
parce que
même si tout le monde se désole qu'entre
un et deux milliards de personnes n'ont
pas qu'ils n'ont pas accès à l'énergie
aujourd'hui sur terre personne ne voyait
la façon de le faire d'une manière qui
soit disons supportable du point de vue
environnemental
tout le monde sait que si on devait
développer dans les continents qui ne
sont pas équipés aujourd'hui en accès à
l'énergie les méthodes que nous avons
appliqué ici en europe ou ailleurs aux
états unis dans les zones développées
ont fait totalement des rails et les
équilibres donc hélas pour la première
fois on voit que n'entrevoit la façon de
le faire parce que je trouve qui est une
avancée majeure
bon même si il ya un certain nombre de
sujets à régler au passage les pays
émergents dont on sait tout un moment
demandé s'il allait suivre ce mouvement
de décarbonisation du mix énergétique
sont maintenant ceux qui tirent la
locomotive
pourquoi parce que voir émerger un
potentiel un gisement des ressources
énergétiques qui ont toujours été là en
fait un soleil et vent qui était
disponible chez eux
techniquement mais pas économiquement du
tout qui était beaucoup trop cher voir
tout ce gisement qui bascule dans des
zones économiques plus plus plus
accessible plus performante c'est pour
eux c'est un changement de décor majeur
et c'est la clé probablement leur
indépendance énergétique donc pas
s'étonner de voir que les pays émergents
sont aujourd'hui ceux qui ont des
objectifs en termes de développement
nous v'la bhl qui sont les plus
importants plus à vrai dire que dans les
zones développées dans lesquelles est
sonné pourtant ces mouvements
développement du renouvelable
bon je pense que dans les pays
développés c'est une bonne nouvelle
aussi on voit bien que les villes
s'asphyxie ya le plan oxygène de la
métropole de lyon qui dit bien ce qui
veut dire je trouve qu'ils comment
est-ce qu'on remet la qualité de l'air
dans dents
dans nos zones urbaines voit bien qu'il
ya des tas de sujets sur lesquels on
commence à buter sur sur l'impact de ces
méthodes qu'on a qu'on a mises en oeuvre
jusque ici donc c'est fondamentalement
une bonne nouvelle énormément de
challenge sont encore devant nous le
principal c'est certainement
l'intermittence en effet alors je crois
que les technologies de stockage et pas
besoin de faire de longs discours elles
sont à l'évidence en train de progresser
moi je crois beaucoup au gaz aussi parce
que on n'a encore jamais fait mieux
pour l'instant en tout cas pour stocker
de l'énergie l'un de nos ingénieurs me
disait il ya quelques jours que pour
stocker sous forme de batteries
l'équivalent de l'énergie qui est
contenue dans un seul de nos stockages
de gaz souterrain chez angie il faut
empiler des dépôts rôles de tesla
jusqu'à la lune et retour alors c'est
une image mais on voit bien quand même
que le stockage de l'électricité à très
grande échelle par des batteries
traditionnelles c'est un vrai challenge
donc il ya des technologies qu'il faut
aller chercher ailleurs et gaz et gaz
vert parce qu'il faudra le verdir
probable ans est une vraie c'est une
vraie thématiques aussi et dans la
catégorie des gaz vers moi à titre
personnel je crois beaucoup à
l'hydrogène
puisque on va avoir des électrons verts
en surplus puisque le solaire en
particulier à la mauvaise habitude de
produire au maximum à midi et quand vous
regardez le profil de consommation bat
midi c'est justement pas là qu'on
consomme le plus donc il ya des
électrons en excès dans certaines
périodes de la journée
si on les si on s'en sert pour provoquer
l'électrolysé de l'eau on sait par
l'hydrogène et l'oxygène et on obtient
de l'hydrogène vert au sens où il n'a
pas émis de de co2 dans l'atmosphère
dont il ya des challenge énormément de
pistes sont en train d'être
débroussaillé par tout un tas d'acteurs
dont angie fait évidemment partie
alors un mot sur
la stratégie que nous nous avons décidé
de suivre
nous sommes un acteur dans l'énergie
depuis plus de cent ans on peut nourrir
à l'orangé d'une certaine manière au
rang des acteurs traditionnels de
l'énergie nous avons fait un choix qui
est de se mettre à la vente cette vague
alors pourquoi parceque bon d'abord on a
beaucoup d'atouts pour le faire au plan
de ce qu'on fait déjà à l'intérieur de
notre groupe
et puis parce que là titre personnel je
suis convaincu que la meilleure façon de
créer de la valeur dans la durée c'est
bien s'aligner sur ce que profondément
les sociétés veulent et donc point de
vue les sociétés d'aujourd'hui elles
veulent cette transition énergétique
donc nous avons fait un choix de se
mettre à l'avant de la vague alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous avons décidé de sortir plus tôt
que les autres de ce qui de notre point
de vue fait partie de dés fin de cycle
donc nous avons en particulier décidé
d'arrêter de produire l'électricité à
partir de charbon nous avons lancé un
plan de cession ou de fermetures
important 15 milliards de cessions qui
sont la traduction directe de ce que je
viens de vous dire donc c'est pas notre
stratégie et les gir et elle a des
implications extrêmement concrètes
ces 15 milliards on les avait réinvestis
dans tout ce qui existe déjà aujourd'hui
comme technologies qui sont prouvés
mature qui fonctionne dans lesquels on
n'est plus dans une zone de recherche et
développement donc il ya trois métiers
que nous faisons un très grande échelle
aujourd'hui
évidemment la production d'électricité
peu ou pas émettrice de co2
deuxièmement le gaz parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quand même ce qu'on fait de mieux
pour compenser l'intermittence du
renouvelable
puis troisième métier c'est ce qu'on
appelle nous les solutions intégrées
parce que je pense qu'on bascule dans un
monde de services
c'est pas c'est pas un mouvement qui est
propre à l'énergie d'ailleurs mais qui
est vrai aussi dans le domaine de
l'énergie donc chez angie peut-être vous
nous connaissez surtout comme un
producteur d'énergie en fait nous sommes
pour les les deux tiers de nos
collaborateurs c'est à dire 100 mille
personnes sur les 155 mille que compte l
j dans 70 pays du monde nous sommes déjà
dans des solutions intégrées c'est à
dire que ou fournis ou pas d'ailleurs à
une énergie propre mais autour de ça ou
fournit un service qui est directement
prêt à l'emploi au fond pourrait le dire
autrement on suit cette énergie jusque
chez vous
jusque sur le site de l'utilisation de
cette énergie et on la rend directement
utilisables alors sous forme de show
sous forme de froid sous forme de vente
à la ventilation d'air sous forme de
circuit et un réseau de recharge de de
transport électrique
voilà donc trois métiers dans lesquels
nous investissons équipe ça ça fait
notre croissance des trois ans qui
viennent et c'est une croissance à +2 5%
si ça c'est c'est pour bien faire
toucher du doigt qu'on est sur des
vraies réalités d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
putatif c'est pas quelque chose d venez
son et de comment dire strictement
futuriste puis en parallèle nous
investissons dans l'innovation pour
préparer maintenant ce qui fera notre
croissance à 5 ans et à 10 ans de noria
l'hydrogène ya les gaz vers donc dont
j'ai parlé moi je pense que pour
terminer justement il faut il faut
accompagner le mouvement
encore un peu plus qu'aujourd'hui ça ne
va pas assez vite ça a été dit tout à
l'heure on entend d'entrée et je crois
que c'est vrai
les technologies les arrivent elles vont
être disponibles c'est sûr maintenant il
ya c'est une course contre la montre et
nous ne sommes pas encore exactement la
bonne vitesse donc il faut changer les
règles du jeu
prix du carbone c'est absolument
indispensable vous avez parlé de l'inde
moi ce que vous juste vous parlez de
laurentins parce que la même europe qui
a massivement investi dans le
développement des renouvelables
en parallèle est en train d'augmenter sa
production d'électricité à partir de
charbon pourquoi parce que le charbon
est très compétitif aujourd'hui les
cours du charbon se sont dits ont baissé
sur la scène internationale ça veut dire
que pour dior d'électricité à partir de
charbon aujourd'hui c'est super
compétitif
bon donc mon avis pas tellement débat je
constate qu'il n'a pas eue là d'ailleurs
tout le monde est assez d'accord pour
dire qu'il faut un prix du carbone pour
rétablir cet équilibre là et faire en
sorte que on arrête la production à
charbon et puis il faut il faut
développer l'innovation
je trouve que
au fond l'europe elle a su développer
des grandes filières technologiques
nucléaire en particulier je n'en dis pas
sur ce qu'a dit jean claude jean marc
jancovici dont il faut qu'on arrive à
s'approprier les technologies
renouvelables du futur on est ça
s'organise à s'organise au niveau des
acteurs privés mais aussi des de la
puissance publique
merci patrick pouyanné bonjour à tous
bon d'abord jeu quand j'aborde ce sujet
je voudrais rappeler simplement que le
monde de l'énergie
il ya quelques fondamentaux le premier
c'est que l'énergie c'est un des
facteurs fondamentaux primaire de
développement économique et social et
que où qu'on aille
le vrai challenge qu'on a c'est que et
sur la planète c'est que quel qu'il soit
quel que soit le pays quelle que soit la
zone
l'homme cherche un à avoir accès à
l'énergie
ça nous paraît évident ici mais c'est
pas à clé c'est pas évident partout sur
la planète
2 à ce qu'elles soient pas cher et le
facteur prix de l'énergie est absolument
fondamentale et 3 et c'est là que ça
devient compliqué on a ajouté il faut
qu'elle soit propre
avec le changement climatique mais le
vrai challenge qu'on a tous c'est d'être
capable de combiner en gros l'axé un
coût abordable avec le fait qu'elle soit
propre
l'accès à un coût abordable c'est déjà
l'âge immédiat pour plein de gens sur
cette planète notamment tous les pays
émergents eux leur priorité aujourd'hui
c'est comment élever le niveau de vie et
pour cela
l'accès à l'énergie pas cher est
essentielle et c'est un accès à un sujet
à court terme le sujet de l'énergie
propre le sujet changement climatique
la vraie difficulté c'est que isabelle à
lille et globale le reste sachez alors
que les décisions se prennent en général
l'échelle d'un pays une entreprise
groupe de gens et puis deuxièmement il
est une échelle de temps plus loin donc
on cherche à régler un problème
d'échelle de temps à 30 40 50 ans un
siècle s'est passé pas loin mais c'est
plus loin que des problèmes de
développement économique qui eux sont à
court terme
et il faut pas se tromper quand on voit
dans les pays émergents enfin je voyage
beaucoup et notamment en asie
aujourd'hui ce qui préoccupe les pays
l'inde par exemple qui est un excellent
exemple
et à quelques temps en inde rencontré mr
électricité d'ailleurs c'est assez
amusant en un ami du pétrole et du gaz
est ministre de l'électricité du charbon
et des renouvelables
les deux ministres est bien celui de
l'électricité les charmant et drôle
almadies oublier le gaz c'est beaucoup
trop cher
nous on fera du charbon et du solaire on
va faire du charbon et pourquoi parce
que la seule ressource naturelle que
nous avons c'est du charbon que ce
deuxièmement nous avons consistant émis
2 % des émissions de co2 sur la planète
et nous voyons pas pourquoi nous on
devrait payer notre énergie plus chère
que les pays développés qui qui eux
eh ben on atteint la qualité de vie
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui le développement
économique donc il ya un vrai un vrai
débat privée reçues ce climat alors
deuxième chose pour tenir ses discours
en fait j'ai pas de moi je vais faire de
mes conférences j'ai pas beaucoup de
discours j'ai juste entre les mains un
seul graphique vous verrez pas qu'elle a
qui est simplement le scénario de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie qui
est un organisme indépendant total nous
tous ce que j'appelle le scénario 2
degrés alors j'ai sur la même planche le
scénario de 3° 5 parce qu'effectivement
pour l'instant on est sur 3 degré 5
je rappelle d'ailleurs que les états
lorsqu'ils ont signé l'accord de paris
après les engagements contractuels enfin
les engagements chaque état et qu'on
n'arrivait pas à 2 degrés la somme de
tous les engagements faisait ils ont un
peu moins de 3 degrés vous qui avez des
efforts à faire
et alors dans chez total on regarde tous
ce sujet pourquoi le regarde ailleurs
parce que fondamentalement ce graphique
il nous dit comment nos marchés vont
évoluer
et alors j'aurai juste le partager avec
vous je me mets en 2040
bon d'abord le point de départ en 2016
je reviendrai là dessus d'abord le
premier constat qu'on fait sur ce
graphique entre 2016 et 2046 on veut
être en 2° c'est que la consommation
dans 25 ans d'énergie doit être à peine
plus importante que celle d'aujourd'hui
5 à 10% alors que la population est
censé passer de 7 milliards mais y'en a
un ennemi qui n'ont pas accès à des
énergies donc cinq et demi aujourd'hui
console
à dix on a 8 milliards donc deux
milliards et demi de plus de gens sac
représente donc un gigantesque efforts
d'efficacité énergétique mais
gigantesque on l'oubli mais le première
condition fondamentale de l'accord de
paris c'est d'éviter de consommer
l'énergie c'est pas du tout évident que
vous dire quand on se promène sur cette
planète parce que tout le monde veut se
développer économiquement accès
l'énergie donc ça c'est le premier
effort après on regarde comment est fait
ce qu'on appelle le mix énergétique en
2000 en 2040
alors aujourd'hui je voudrais juste
rappeler quelque chose je vais répondre
aux questions le mix énergétique
actuelle je suis vous le savez tous mais
je le répète mondial c'est 30% de
charbon 30% de pétrole 20 % de gaz 80%
des énergies fossiles qui paraît qu'il
n'existe plus et puis après vous ajoutez
5 % 5 6% nucléaire 5 6% diderot
électrique comme ça a été dit qui est le
premier énergies renouvelables parce
qu'elle est condensée entrer il faut
ajouter de la biomasse mais la biomasse
actuellement n'est pas une bonne
biomasse c'est malheureusement dès les
pays émergents des gens qui font de la
cuisine avec du bois biomasse qui fait
du co2 et puis les énergies
renouvelables et 3%
ça c'est l'actuel ce qui est frappant
dans ce que je viens de décrire
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il ya encore 30 % de
charbon est considéré par nous comme une
énergie du passé
ça fait un siècle et demi qu'on le
produit est pourquoi mais parce que le
charbon c'est l'énergie qui est la plus
simple a produit et la moins coûteuse
l'arrivée c'est tout simple mais encore
30% alors que si on se met en 2040 à 2
degrés qu'est ce qu'on lit dans les
scénarios la danse à cergy ben le
pétrole alors le charbon devrait tomber
de 30 à 15 %
le pétrole tomberez de 30 à 20 % 20 à
22% et le gaz passerait de 20 à 25%
il resterait quand même encore 60 %
d'énergies fossiles en 2040 2050
alors je reviendrai sur les conditions
de cela et après les énergies
renouvelables trouverez une place
importante de l'ordre de 30% et donc
qu'il faut pas à croire que le la
transition elle doit avoir lieu mais les
peines en plus radicale enfin je veux
dire et simplement ce challenge là
aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes les
technologies pour l'atteindre présent
pour le pétrole ça voudrait dire qu'au
lieu de
produire 100 millions de barils on
devrait en produire que 75 mais véhicule
électrique ça n'élimine que 8 millions
de barils par jour si tous les véhicules
et elle écrit sur cette planète
la moitié des véhicules électriques en
2040 donc la solution
il ya plein d'efforts technologie à
faire alors pour faire cela il ya
quelques éléments qui me paraissent
alors est-ce que ça va lentement oui
mais il faut croire aussi à l'évolution
des technologies je suis un très
optimiste sur le très optimiste sur le
plan technologique parce que encore une
fois
isabelle les dix mois en 2000 ou en 2005
on parlait pas d'énergie solaire ou
l'énergie éolienne c'est pas si vieux
que ça c'était il ya dix ans qu'est ce
qui a fait d'ailleurs qu'on en parle et
je vais revient sur le prix c'est
simplement que le prix du pétrole est
monté à 100 dollars et comme le prix du
pétrole est monté à 100 dollars et les
devenus trop chers et donc tout le monde
s'est retroussé les manches pour dire
des bons vieux il faut trouver une
énergie moins chère et ce sans dollars
du pétrole a permis à a été le driver de
l'ena de l'émergence et de des gens qui
sont libres maintenant il faut améliorer
ces technologies solaires comme total et
lorsqu'on invite investi là-dedans
donc le signal prix est fondamentale et
c'est pour ça que sur le sujet prix du
carbone
bien sûr qu'il faut à prix du carbone et
pour et si total à la surprise de
beaucoup de gens est devenu un avocat du
prix du carbone mais c'est simplement
parce que dans le débat gaz charbon le
gaz et la bonne énergie puisqu'il est
une centrale électrique au gaz et mais
deux fois moins de co2 qu'il centrale et
les clochards bon et d'ailleurs juste en
rêvant à 2 minutes 10 secondes
si nous étions capables aujourd'hui de
transformer tous les centrales au
charbon de cette planète en centrale à
gaz
nous serions immédiatement sur le
scénario de donnerai c'est pas des
grandes technologies ce que j'ai à dire
c'est juste un problème de mentalité
c'est pas impossible puisque les sens
très à l'aise on les connaît on les
maîtrise très bien ont immédiatement du
sirion bon à l'entraînement il faut
convaincre beaucoup de grands pays chine
inde états unis de le faire donc le
signal prix carbone est essentielle dans
ce débat là et il ya un pays qui l'a
démontré c'est le royaume uni il l'a
fait en live
l'angleterre a des défauts veut quitter
l'europe elle a une qualité c'est que
les britanniques ont décidé de mettre
une taxe sur le co2
18 livres 18 livres ça fait 20 euros 22
euros plus le tsv 25 euros 25 euros la
tonne
ça vient de se passer depuis deux ans et
demi trois ans en grande bretagne le
système électrique britannique a shift
et du charbon au gaz immédiatement donc
c'est pas des grandes théories chez bien
qu'on parle de prix mondial alors je
suis pas un grand fan du prix mondial je
sais que la théorie économique dit qu'il
veut qu'il soit mondial et parce que si
on veut qu'il soit un mondial c'est le
meilleur moyen de javel atteindre jamais
on ne mettra d'accord l'inde et l'europe
sur le même prix du carbone déjà mais
c'est juste une vue de l'esprit
et donc il faut être pragmatique alors
là c'est peut-être le côté praticiens
déjà faisons le chez nous et pourquoi il
ya pas de prix de carbone en europe mais
parce que personne ne le veux vous dire
et on fait des systèmes hyper compliqué
qui s'appelle le ts et je voyais le
nouvel obs il marchera pas mieux que
l'ancien pour une bonne raison c'est que
d'ailleurs s'ils devaient marcher vous
devriez entendre plus de gens râler et
vous entendez personnes râler
aujourd'hui donc on a fait un règlement
super compliqué auquel franchement ont
décidé chiffres 800 millions de tonnes
de réserves à gauche pas de tombe ce
chiffre parce que tout le monde bouge et
puis à personnes qui râlent donc tous
les lobbys sont contents ça veut dire
que ça va pas marcher moi je suis
convaincu qu'on va passer de cinq à huit
et qu'on va constater que ça marche pas
en fait il ya un moyen simple c'est
juste décidé à un prix il faut pas qu'il
soit très haut il faut pas qu'il soit
très haut parce que si on dit qu'on va
le mettre à 50 cent on fait peur à tout
le monde
le prix du carbone est essentielle pour
une autre raison c'est parce qu'en fait
et notamment parce que si je décris le
monde que j'ai décrit à un moment on
veut une neutralité carbone donc il faut
éliminer les émissions de co2 liées au
gaz et au pétrole
ça s'appelle les technologies de capture
et de stockage de co2 il faudra stocker
du co2 ou le transformer en produit
chine et en matière aux matériaux ce qui
est une voix est là à voir un prix du
carbone c'est extrêmement utile pour
driver l'innovation sachant que je suis
convaincu qu'il faut pas aller à 100
cher pas aller chercher 600 dollars la
turn ont fait pleurer tellement une
boîte comme total si nous payons 30 dans
l'arrêt tonnes sur toutes nos émissions
de co2 ça représenterait 3 4 milliards $
par an tu peux vous dire que si je dois
payer 3 ou 4 milliards de taxes par an
la recherche et développement va
s'accélérer très très très vite
y a pas besoin de m'expliquer et mes
ingénieurs et mes équipes
ils vont vite trouver les moyens donc il
faut un prix il faudrait déjà que
l'europe le fasse parce qu'on a un côté
l'europe et quelques grands pays
développés
la californie leurs états unis pour
l'instant c'est compliqué même si il ya
des mouvements y compris côté
républicain qui se prononce de plus en
plus pour il faut des choses comme cela
voilà ce que je voulais dire
alors nous face à sabha total ben nous
on continue à devoir fournir l'énergie
donc on est un groupe pétrolier de plus
en plus gazier on l'affirmé et qui
investit aussi dans le champ des
énergies renouvelables parce que
fondamentalement on veut suivre
l'évolution de nos marchés
merci autres acteurs un propos qui va
d'abord bonjour à toutes et à tous
pardon un propos qui va pas être
technologique
vous vous en doutez simplement
je supplie année et isabelle kocher luiz
qui s'est finalement quand on parle
d'énergie on parle
de notre quotidien pourquoi parce que
derrière il ya un certain nombre
d'enjeux qui sont des enjeux vous l'avez
évoqué des enjeux sociétaux des enjeux
environnementaux des enjeux
environnementaux d'abord vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la qualité de
l'air aujourd'hui la qualité de l'air je
resterai sur à l'échelle de la métropole
est un enjeu bien sûr de santé publique
tout le monde l'a en tête mais c'est
aussi un enjeu d'attractivité parce que
dans cette métropole aujourd'hui les
entreprises qui souhaitent s'implanter
dans la métropole
il y a quelques années en arrière la
qualité de l'air n'était pas un sujet
aujourd'hui devient un sujet
d'attractivité et les responsables
d'entreprises qui souhaitent s'implanter
nous demande qu'est ce que nous allons
prendre comme mesures pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air quel est notre
trajectoire pour ahlem améliorer la
qualité de l'air car nos entreprises nos
talents ne viendront pas dans une
métropole qui n'a pas un objectif qui
n'a pas des objectifs en matière
d'amélioration de la qualité de l'air ça
c'est le premier enjeu le deuxième enjeu
c'est un enjeu c'est un enjeu social
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
maîtrise de l'énergie maîtrise aussi du
coût de l'énergie parce que directement
au quotidien ceci vient impacter
finalement les personnes les plus
vulnérables et quelque part aussi des
personnes les plus démunies dans notre
métropole et c'est un sujet extrêmement
important cette maîtrise de la dépense
en énergie et des économies d'énergie et
donc pour répondre à ces différents
sujets bien il y avait plusieurs
en tout cas tenté de répondre et faire
finalement d'une métropole qui soit en
même temps dans l'attractivité mais qui
sont en même temps inclusive c'est à
dire attentive à ces à ces problèmes là
on avait une solution c'était d'attendre
que les choses se passent et que les
choses arrivent dans hop il y avait une
deuxième solution c'est de se dire
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
maîtriser un peu plus notre destin
l'échelle d'un territoire comment est ce
qu'on fait pour au moins modestement
peser sur notre destin en matière
d'énergie alors on a fait une première
chose on a fait quand je dis nous avons
fait c'est pas simplement la métropole
c'est avec l'ensemble des partenaires
dont certains sont ici d'ailleurs
représenté sur 7 sur ces deux tribunes
mais aussi avec des associations avec
des entreprises avec un certain nombre
de nos habitants samedi on va faire un
plan
énergie climat territorial en se fixant
des objectifs c'est des objectifs assez
classique des trois fois 20 c'est moins
20% de consommation d'énergie c'est -20%
d'émissions de co2 et c'est + 20 %
d'énergies renouvelables et puis avec
ces objectifs là on a décliné un certain
nombre un certain nombre d'actions les
premières ont porté leurs fruits parce
que finalement cette métropole très
attractive mais là en disant prix + 10 %
de population et nous avons baissé nos
émissions de -12% donc un certain nombre
d'actions se sont déclinées à l'échelle
des territoires mais aussi en lien
étroit avec avec les industriels et puis
la loi nous à nous a aidés puisque
depuis 2015
les métropoles et la métropole de lyon
et responsable à la compétence énergie
et donc nous sommes aujourd'hui en
responsabilité sur les distribution
d'énergie gaz électricité des énergies
renouvelables les réseaux de chaleur est
donc parti de là nous sommes face à une
grande responsabilité face à cette
grande responsabilité nous avons décliné
avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires un
certain nombre d'actions concrètes et je
voudrais redescendre sur ses actions
concrètes qui sont en lien avec
l'ensemble de nos compétences que nous
avons la chance d'avoir les compétences
sur l'habitat sur l'urbanisme sur le
logement sur l'assainissement sur la
collecte des déchets et donc nous avons
mis en mouvement un certain nombre de
compétences un certain nombre d'actions
pardon la première c'était de dire à nos
prestataires le développement du
chauffage urbain les réseaux de chaud et
de froid il faut aller plus loin en
matière d'énergies renouvelables il faut
se fixer un objectif qui aujourd'hui de
62 ou 65 % d'énergies renouvelables il
faut tripler les raccordements au tour
du réseau de chaleur de froid du réseau
du réseau urbain ce qui bien évidemment
répond à ses objectifs et puis nous
avons travaillé beaucoup avec les
industriels et et sur les process
industriels et notamment sur ce qu'on
appelle l'approvisionnement innovant
c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on
récupère ce qu'on appelle la chaleur
fatale et en particulier ici pour celles
et ceux qui habitent la métropole qui
connaissent un peu la vallée de la
chimie
on voit toutes ces fumées qui qui qui
partent dans le ciel et c'est cet enjeu
de récupérer cette chaleur fatale pour
un faire de l'énergie qu'on peut
réutiliser dans les process dans les
process industriels
ça a été aussi vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure sur le photovoltaïque la mise à
disposition aujourd'hui dans un grand
appel à projets de 87 mille mètres
carrés de foncier dans la vallée de la
chimie pour y installer des panneaux
photovoltaïques une réponse
supplémentaire autour des énergies
renouvelables et puis c'est sur la
consommation d'énergie bien ma foi c'est
un plan d'éco-rénovation pour
accompagner les particuliers qui veulent
isoler leur logement qu'il soit seul ou
en copropriété
c'est bien sûr le tout le travail autour
autour de la mobilité des nouvelles
mobilités
un plan oxygène vous l'avez évoqué
isabelle kocher avec prochainement une
zone de faible émission qui nous
permettra aussi de peser sur l'entrée
des véhicules les plus polluants sur
notre notre métropole
voilà ce que nous avons ce que nous
tentons de faire de façon assez modeste
mais de toute façon assez comment dire
responsable moi j'entendais l'ensemble
des interventions et je pense que c'est
des actions mis bout-à-bout à l'échelle
des territoires qui permettent sans
doute de répondre à ces à ces défis
autour de autour de l'énergie
je finirai juste par une formule ce que
ce que nous on souhaite si c'est
finalement avoir la bonne énergie au bon
endroit et au bon moment et pour ça on
pense que les territoires ont un rôle
extrêmement important à jouer aux côtés
des grands acteurs de l'énergie bien
évidemment merci
voir interagir entre entre vous qui
n'êtes pas toujours d'accord mais
surtout avec la salle qui commence à
poser des questions alors il y en a
plusieurs et de tous ordres mais il y en
a une qui m'intéresse et ton le patro le
pétrole et le charbon n'est-il pas trop
bon marché pour qu'on passe à autre
chose faut-il le surtaxés et une autre
question du même genre nos économies ont
vécu avec un baril à 100 dollars
c'était même un moment intéressant
pourquoi ne pas avoir maintenu ce prix
avec des taxes j'ai pas de problème
d'ailleurs le pétrole est énormément
taxé enfin je matin depuis ce matin
d'ailleurs c'est amusant cheval et rodez
j'ai eu deux interviews il se trouve
qu'il ya une nouvelle comme quoi le prix
de l'essence augmente en france
et bien c'est panique à bord donc c'est
la faute du pétrole qui monte mais dans
le prix de l'essence il ya 70 % de taxes
oui maintenant pas augmenté la semaine
dernière
oui mais elles vont augmenter un peu
plus le 1er janvier je peux vous dire
beaucoup plus parce que est beaucoup
plus puisque le gouvernement a décidé
d'habiller le diesel sur le sur
l'essence donc je moi je vois des
grandes contradictions c'est à dire d'un
côté et ça renvoie ce que j'ai dit on
dit on est tous d'accord il faut aller
vers une énergie plus prod donc des
éleveurs monter la qualité de l'air mais
de l'autre côté dès que le prix de
l'énergie augmentent
panique à bord est naturellement comme
par hasard cette communication est venue
du gouvernement pourrait fixer la faute
des pétroliers alors que dans le prix de
l'essence nous ne faisons que 30% du
prix non mais le sénat qui a été pressé
une forme de dons les taxes non mais le
prix du carbone c'est une forme de taxe
j'ai pas de problème si je dis que
j'étais favorable
on peut y aller on peut faire le prix du
carbone et de toute manière si on
l'appliquent
effectivement au co2 celui qu'on va
pénaliser le premier ça va être le
charbon est immédiatement le gaz devient
plus complexe que charbon à 20 euros la
tonne
il faut pas 25 il faut pas il faut pas
il faut pas à 100 euros c'est pas vrai
donc donc je pensais qu'on est favorable
à parce que ce sera très pratique et
comme les d'isabelle le gaz c'est
l'énergie flexible celi d'euros car les
drôles hydrocarbures fossiles qui permet
de mieux se combiner à l'intermittence d
des renouvelables donc on n'a pas de
problème là dessus alors pourquoi pas le
prix du pétrole y baissent parce que
quand le prix est élevé indépendamment
de qui le fait qu'ils ouvrent les
nouvelles technologies il ya plein de
gens qui investissent et quand il
investit s'y produisent trop et quand
ils produisent trop bas le prix tombe
parce que parce que quand il est élevé
il ya un deuxième effet c'est comme les
cours d'économie la demande et pour
moins forte donc pris et lui est égal
trop de d'euros d'investissements dans
trop d'offre pas assez de demandes parce
que prix trop cher et puis une nouvelle
technologie qui viennent en concurrence
donc ça se casse la figure les clients
en ce moment qu'est ce qui se passe
ben comme on a moins d'argent on
investit moins donc y aura moins
d'offres comme le prix du pétrole est
pas cher la demande explose il faut
qu'il faut savoir que la demande de
pétrole mondiale
malgré tout ce que je dis sur le climat
elle va augmenter en trois ans deux fois
plus vite que les trois années
précédentes
on n'a jamais vu une aussi grande
croissance en ce moment là 15 16 17
parce qu'il est pas cher et puis
effectivement c'est pas bon pour les
causes energy company concurrentes mais
le problème c'est que l'idée de
stabiliser du prix du pétrole c'est
juste une vue de l'esprit est une taxe
pourrait le faire mais j'entends plutôt
des gens qui veulent qu'on enlève les
subventions au pétrole qui ont lieu à
droite à gauche pour essayer de le
cantonner donc je pense que on a des
matières premières qui dont la
fluctuation suis des lois de freud la
demande mais le prix du co2 qui est une
externalité par rapport à tous ces choix
d'énergie est la bonne réponse puisque
si on met un prix du co2 on price et
donc on est on est on met le prix
d'accès réalité dans le prix des
énergies et du coup on choisira en
fonction de cette contrainte si on la
veut si on veut vraiment la mettre sur
la table
voilà comment je vois le sujet tant à
faire un petit complément par rapport à
ce qui a été dit auquel je souscris tout
à fait là la manière de faire monter le
prix d'une énergie le prix du co2 et une
taxe comme une autre il ya deux façons
de le faire ou bien on attend que pour
des questions de raréfaction de l'offre
ce soit le prix qui montent tout seul
sur le marché ou bien on décide de taxer
délibérément l' usage dans le deuxième
cas de figure le consommateur peut pas
se plaindre de ce que le citoyen a
souhaité un moment il faut quand même
qu'ils se mettent d'accord avec lui même
il ya une énorme différence entre la
taxe à la consommation et la hausse sur
le marché c'est que l'argent va pas dans
la même poche
si vous taxez à la consommation c'est de
l'argent qui ne sort pas du pays
la fiscalité elle alimente le pays donc
on vous prend dans la poche gauche et
puis on vous remet dans la poche droite
des enseignants des flics même si vous
souhaitez pas y avoir à faire des juges
si vous souhaitez en par mois y avoir à
faire et autres choses de cette nature
que l'état vous fournit alors que si
vous attendez que le prix monde tout
seul sur le marché à ce moment l'argent
il va pas chez les fonctionnaires
français il va chez les fonctionnaires
russes qui comme chacun sait sont
beaucoup plus soucieux de notre sort que
les fonctionnaires français cetc il ya
une énorme différence
non mais souvent j'ai entendu dire il
suffit d'attendre que le prix du pétrole
monte à ce moment on fera ce qu'il faut
dans un pays qui importe la totalité de
ces hydrocarbures
il me semble que c'est un peu
dommageable de raisonner ainsi parce que
ça veut dire en gros qu'on accepte
l'idée que l'argent va aller chez les
autres
lorsqu'on parle du problème du prix du
carbone il ya évidemment d'être de toute
une série de solutions différentes mais
un des éléments de discussion chez les
économistes
je reprends reprendra casquette c'est
l'effet que la politique en question
il s'agit d'une politique de taxation
une politique de de mise en place d'un
marché droit et à la laisser
c'est l'effet qu'elle aura sur le prix
des carburants fossiles sur le prix du
pétrole
on a des indices on a dit très souvent
que une taxe carbone mal conçu
diminuerait le prix du pétrole et donc
que son effet incitatif sur le prix
total du carbone serait plus faible il
ya un économiste allemand très connu en
interne heurts signe qui a beaucoup
écrit là-dessus et d'un débat sur les
bonnes manières de procéder à
l'affichage d'un prix du carbone
l'interaction entre la méthode que l'on
utilise et le prix du pétrole par
exemple est un des éléments importants
de la discussion ce que je vais dire
d'accord que ce que nous faisons en
france c'est justement ce qu'il faut pas
faire on se targue un moment en ce
moment de faire des taxes sur le co2 ont
lessivé des accises sur les carburants
ça n'a aucun impact sur la campagne le
comportement des consommateurs parce que
pour eux il voit un prix de l'essence ce
n'est pas la bonne façon de faire ça n'a
pas d'impact mais je veux dire c'est pas
on dit qu'on est en train d'augmenter la
taxe sur le carbone dans la fiscalité
française
oui ou non on augmente les taxes sur les
carburants et comme les gens de toutes
manières doivent les utiliser il les
utilise et ça n'a pas d'impact sur le
comportement des gens c'est pas vrai ça
n'a pas d'impact au d'ailleurs non plus
sur l'évolution des technologies en
question
c'est pas une taxe incitative et pas
l'espagne taxation écologique
incitatives c'est pas vrai une question
de la salle si si tout le monde je
voudrais évoquer moi un grand absent
dans tout ça c'est les économies
d'énergie parce que depuis tout à
l'heure on est en train alors par par
différentes voies mais dire en gros le
prix de l'énergie risque de monter soit
parce qu'on va taxer d de plus en plus d
énergies carbonées soit parce que on va
passer à du renouvelables stockage qui
est encore très cher aujourd'hui
bref toute façon c'est difficile
d'imaginer à court terme je pense que ça
viendra ensuite mais seulement ensuite
et des prix énergie qui baissent donc la
variable de bouclage qui est absolument
indispensable à tout point de vue qu'on
parle de précarité énergétique on parle
de compétitivité industrielle qu'on
parle de simplement caractère
supportable du prix l'énergie pour nous
tous
la variable de bouclage dont je trouve
personne ne parle ce sont les économies
d'énergie je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
nous nous efforçons de suivre l'énergie
jusque dans ses usages et on s'aperçoit
à chaque fois qu'on le fait et à chaque
fois qu'on se met à gérer vraiment
finement big data à l'appui algorithmes
logiciels qui capteurs et cetera digital
à l'appui quand on commence à faire ça
on arrive à a généré 20 % 30 %
d'économie d'énergie assez couramment
pas absolument systématiquement mais
assez couramment mais c'est pas marginal
ce dont je saurai me parlait alors
vraiment je trouve ça me fera parce que
dans tous les pays dans lesquels nous
nous sommes présents la traduction la
plus fréquente de la transition
énergétique c'est développement massif
des renouvelables
très bien mais faut pas oublier la
composante négawatt si on peut l'appeler
comme ça parce que sans elle assez vite
je pense on va buter contre contre une
sorte de limite qui va être celle de la
compétitivité des prix de l'énergie
or encore une fois les technologies sont
disponibles
on peut gagner massivement 20% 30% pour
un confort égal parfois supérieures de
la consommation d'énergie aujourd'hui
dans le mot sur la taxe carbone parce
que en vous écoutant quelqu'un a demandé
mais plus que tout le monde est d'accord
sur cette sueur dans cette salle
pourquoi cette taxe carbone n'a pas n'a
pas lieu mais parce que ceux qui ne
veulent pas ne sont pas là alors c'est
qui mais c'est l'utilisateur sont les
utilisateurs d'énergie vais je veux dire
mais j'ai une anecdote que j'en aurai
peña mais moi j'étais patron du
raffinage et de la pétrochimie total un
moment où il fallait tout restructurer
en europe
j'étais le plus fervent opposant à une
taxe sur le carbone parce que j'étais un
énorme consommateur d'énergie
je suis devenu patron de total et j'ai
réalisé au bout de huit jours qu'il
fallait que je devienne pro carbone pro
taxe carbone oui comme quoi on change en
fonction des critères sur lesquels on
est jugé non mais y aller il n'y a pas
les absents dans la cette salle ce sont
les gens qui sont des gros consommateurs
d'énergie et en europe
l'ensemble des industriels qui ont des
gros consommateurs et notamment il faut
être clair les chimistes allemands et
autres manufacturiers allemands ne
veulent pas que la taxe pour ça quand je
disais le thé et marcel ts marchera pas
la preuve vous entendez personnes
pleurer alors il faudrait être capable
de combiner ça a été dit par patrick
artus la taxe carbone sur l'europe avec
l'air le président macron l'a repris
dans ses propositions
un concept de deux taxes à l'import
enfin de ce qui est objectivement quand
on étudie le sujet vu de l'om c est
extrêmement compliqué à établir
extrêmement compliquée j'en ai
longuement parlé avec notre notre ancien
directeur général de l omc pascal lamy
l'uimm dit ça tient pas la route d'un
point du commerce international mais
mais c'est clair qu'il ya un risque de
fuite de carbone si l'europe tout seul
mais une taxe à mon avis c'est pas de ta
ferrer si on va à 15 euros 20 euros le
système industriel européen peut peut
absorber 15,20 euros et faire des
efforts qui à mon avis peuvent même de
donner comme l'a dit isabelle un resort
de compétitivité qu'on pourra exporter
derrière pour voir les sujets positifs
jeu il faut arrêter d'être frileux sur
ce sujet d'où le fait que que je me suis
nous nous sommes positionnés même
château là où j'ai aussi je vous rappel
jusqu'au consommateur à finhan
pétrochimistes sur une taxe raisonnable
qui permettrait de faire bouger tout le
système parce qu'on se dit
sans nécessairement une border taxe qui
viendrait compléter truc qui me paraît
très compliquée à mettre en oeuvre ceci
étant j'ai l'impression que président
trump est en train d'en introduire une
législation fiscale pas la même et enfin
oui mais tout ça c'est le même mouvement
de protectionnisme oui juste un point
une taxe carbone on peut l'imaginer au
niveau mondial on peut les imaginer au
niveau européen
moi j'ai tout à l'heure quand j'ai parlé
taxe carbone j'ai parlé de taxe carbone
au niveau européen avec un mécanisme
d'ajustement aux frontières
éventuellement j'ai lancé l'idée comme
ça sur le tapis mais au niveau européen
on avait mis à la place de la taxe
carbone ne marchait de schémas de
démission de de european trading skim le
lui était est ce qu'avec le mans place
et qui concerne 50% des émissions enfin
la démission du secteur industriel et
pas les émissions de l'ensemble de des
européens pourquoi on n'a pas pris un
taxe carbone bien pour des raisons
juridiques
on peut créer un marché de droits en
europe à la majorité des états on ne
peut pas créer une taxe sans unanimité
même s'ils savaient les effets tout à
fait identique en l'occurrence il ya eu
il ya une difficulté juridique
je pense que pour l'europe la bonne
solution aurait été de fait une crème
taxe carbone au sens strict du terme
voilà jean marc jancovici de complément
la première alors là je vais m'inscrire
un peu en porte-à-faux est ce qu a dit
patrick pouyanné en disant à 30 ou 40
euros les industriels meurs je ne suis
pas complètement sûr quand le baril
passe de 50 à 100 dollars
c'est comme si on rajoutait une taxe
carbone à 100 euros la tonne de co2 il y
a le baril je crois est passé de 50 à
100 dollars il est même resté à 100 $
pendant quelques années on n'a pas vu la
totalité de l'industrie s'écrouler donc
il ya quelques personnes tu vois oui
c'est vrai mais bon par ailleurs il ya
quand même beaucoup d'industriels qui
crie avant même d'avoir mal si on prend
l'exemple du ciment le ciment est un
pont d re pas délocalisables les
cimentiers quand il crie aux propos du
prix du carbone c'est une posture
tout ça c'est du grand guignol c'est
pareil pour une partie des autres
pondéreux enfin c'est juste histoire
d'être comme d'être accord avec leurs
petits copains c'est pas au sein du
syndicat des industriels
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que la taxe en fait
et là je suis je vais de nouveau
d'accord avec patrick elle a aucune
raison d'arrivée de manière homogène
mondialement donc en fait il ya déjà
pour répondre à la question qui a été
posée des taxes carbone qui arrive en
europe l'année prochaine elle va passer
à 45 euros la tonne de co2 en france sur
les consommations domestiques d'énergie
les suédois en ont mis une chez eux les
uns disent les anglais en ont remis une
chez eux sur l'électricité etc
donc il en arrive mais le grand soir si
cher aux français qui adore les systèmes
blanc et noirs lui par contre qui
voudrait que instantanément on en est
une hache pourquoi 55,2 euros la tonne
applicables mondialement partout et tout
le temps celle là elle arrivera jamais
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
a été dit tout à l'heure
david kimelfeld je suis assez frappé par
je suis assez frappé par le débat qui
tournerait depuis un petit moment autour
de la taxe la taxe les taxes le coup on
va parler d'innovation après il ya des
faits je pense que
je pense qu'il ya non mais c'était la
question posée mais je n'ai bien entendu
la question mais simplement je pense
qu'il y à d'autres d'autres réponses
complémentaires
isabelle kocher par led et de l'économie
d'énergie qui est un élément extrêmement
important et donc de la même façon que
le changement des comportements est
extrêmement important en matière
d'énergie c'est pas simplement un marché
des taxes des coûts
c'est aussi des comportements qui se
modifie ses comportements il ne se
modifie qui s'il ya bien sûr une
alternative proposer des alternatives
proposées
tu adores j'évoquais mois la mobilité
qui est une façon de faire baisser la
consommation d'énergie parce que quand
dans un pays dans une métropole dans une
ville où on développe des réseaux de
mobilité autre que la voiture qu'on
offre cette alternative pas qu'on soit
vraie contrainte mais qu'on offre c'est
peut-être la native de fait on amène une
réponse certes modeste à l'échelle
mondiale à la consommation d'énergie
quand on pousse l'innovation sur la
construction quand on pousse un certain
nombre de ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
des écoquartiers qui aujourd'hui se
fixent notamment comme objectif de
consommer moins de co2 en 2025 qu'ils
ont consommé en 2000 je pense que c'est
aussi une réponse en matière de
consommation d'énergie
et puis je pense qu' il y a aussi une
volonté je pense collectif crois qu'il
ya une prise de conscience qui va au
delà des taxes qui va au delà du coût de
l'énergie une prise de conscience de
l'état du monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
en matière de développement durable je
pense qu'il faut compter aussi sur cette
bonne volonté et d est bien accompagné
de la population pour prendre conscience
qu'il s'agit pas simplement des taxes et
pour avoir peur mais d'avoir un
comportement responsable pour consommer
moins je pense que c'est aussi une des
pistes d'amélioration de la situation
patrick artus
or dire sur la question globale puisque
isabelle nous parle de son entreprise
qui vit donc peut avoir une stratégie
extrêmement différentes si on prend la
chance globalement sur un simple en vue
du 2 nd j le problème on est tous elle
m'a dit s'il me semble
le problème c'est que c'est pas vraiment
ce ne sont pas les pays de l' ocde dans
les pays de l'osce et dieu la
consommation de ces les émissions de co2
diminuent et on est sur une trajectoire
relativement vertueuse et le diminue de
pratiquement 1% par an le problème ce
sont le problème ce sont ceux sont les
émergents dans les pays émergents la
consommation d'énergie augmente de
presque 4% par an et avec une
sensibilité aux prix qui est
extraordinairement faibles donc je sais
pas combien avron comment on vient à
bout de ce problème
autant nous on pourra avoir des taxes
carbone en europe
d'ailleurs faut rappeler que si on met
une taxe que les autres n'ont pas
normalement le taux de change a juste eu
ras quand on est sa monnaie on a le
droit de voir des taxes qui sont pas les
mêmes des autres donc l'argument de
compétitivité européenne il est comme
extraordinairement coûteux donc on
pourra avoir une taxe carbone européenne
ça réglera absolument rien du problème
global qui le problème d aimer des
consommations d'énergie et des émissions
de co2 des émergents et ce problème là
patrick et isabelle en parlait il est
absolument inextricable
1 parce que on n'a pas dont on a pas de
possibilités technologiques d'offrir aux
émergents un autre un autre mix
énergétique rapidement que celui qu'ils
utilisent aujourd'hui et qui fabrique 4%
de croissance de leurs émissions de co2
il ya beaucoup de questions sur les
technologies l'innovation notamment
pourquoi on n'utilise pas plus la
chaleur de la terre
est ce que quelqu'un a une réponse là
dessus la géothermie c'est ça qui est
visée ne l'a pas tant que ça tout
simplement ça c'est une énergie qui se
déplace très très mal donc en gros quand
vous avez une source géothermique faut
mettre la centrale électrique quasiment
sur la source parce que sinon ça c'est
très inefficace donc c'est pas c'est pas
très rentable en fait visible
je sais pas du tout intéressant pour
faire de l'électricité parce que
monsieur carnot a dit que pour faire de
l'électricité ce qui comptait c'était la
différence de température entre la
source chaude et la source froide et en
allant chercher les calories dans les
entrailles de la terre c'est pas très
intéressant mais il répond par contre il
ya un usage qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est pour remplacer
je suis désolé pour mes deux voisins de
droite le gaz et le pétrole dans le
chauffage des habitations
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pompe à
chaleur donc la pompe à chaleur en gros
va chercher des calories dans l'air ou
dans le sol c'est plus efficace dans le
sol ça coûte plus cher et ça c'est une
énorme marge demeure donc c'est une
énergie renouvelable est en fait tout à
l'heure roger guesnerie a joué à si
j'étais dictateur moi je vais jouer à 6
gt macron si j'étais macron je passerai
demain matin les cinq ou six milliards
d'euros de subventions aux énergies
renouvelables électriques
on est en train de fournir dans ce pays
aux pompes à chaleur pour remplacer le
gaz et le fioul de chauffage
voilà c'est tout autant des nerfs et là
par contre on tape dans 15 à 20 % des
émissions de co2 du pays
[Applaudissements]
je suis absolument d'accord avec vous
dans la géothermie c'est que c'est une
source renouvelable non intermittente
à vrai dire c'est la seule et vous
pomper dans le sol la chaleur que vous
avez besoin vous l'a laissé dormir
surtout quand vous n'en avez pas besoin
donc c'est en termes de souplesse c'est
excellent alors quand on disqualifie la
géothermie en général c'est parce qu'on
pense modèle centralisé et on pense
grande usine de production d'électricité
grande usine de production d'énergie moi
je pense que le monde se décentralise du
point de vue l'énergie non seulement il
des carbonise ça c'était le mouvement
initial c'est comme ça que sont nées les
technologies renouvelables c'est la
volonté décarbonés très bien il se
trouve que et ça c'était ce n'était pas
écrit d'avancé
les technologiques qui ont maturé peu
depuis dix ans elle se décentralise très
bien c'est à dire elles sont peu les
accommoder à très grande échelle est
offert en construit les très grandes
fermes éoliennes solaires qui font des
hectares entiers c'est ça peut être
gigantesque et en même temps c'est
efficace à petite échelle ce qui fait
qu'on se met à penser le monde de
l'énergie autrement ou l'énergie aie les
spécialistes nous disent à terme elle
sera probablement assez massivement
produite sur le lieu même de la
consommation on nous dit jusqu'à 50%
alors 50 pensons c'est très loin d'ici
c2050 60 puis c'est 1 50% qui vaut ce
qu'il vaut mais est quand même c'est un
c'est un autre mouvement de fond ça fait
bien dans ce contexte là il rebondit sur
la géothermie puisque alors là
typiquement la géothermie s'inscrit dans
ce modèle décentralisé vous aller pomper
la chaleur de la terre au droit de votre
maison ou de la ville vous alimenter des
réseaux de chaud ça marche très bien
simplement il faut changer de changer de
logique et se dire que une partie
importante de l'énergie désormais elle
sera produite gérer consommer sur place
on n'a pas le président de la république
mais on a le représentant de la
métropole il ya des questions sur les
subventions et notamment celle ci
pourquoi la métropole n'êtes pas à
l'acquisition de véhicules électriques
sa sélection pour la vie de fille qui
m'a fait non d'abord d'abord la
métropole effectivement ne à ce stade la
dette pas là à l'acquisition de
véhicules électriques sauf si vous
considérez que les vélos électriques
sont des véhicules et auquel cas la
métropole accompagne a déjà accompagné
et qu'on irait accompagnera à partir du
mois de janvier parce qu'elle prendra là
la suite de la prime qui était qui a été
institué une prime nationale pour
accompagner celles et ceux qui prennent
achètent des vélos électriques et moi
j'ai proposé qu'on met à l'étude pour
monter d'un cran
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui utilisent
des vélos électriques utilitaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui se développe en tout cas
dans notre ville un certain nombre
d'artisans de professionnels qui
utilisent des vélos électriques pour
aller or c'est ce sont des artisans des
plombiers un certain nombre
d'électricien enfin je passe notamment
celles et ceux aussi qui font du soin
domicile enfin on essaye de réfléchir à
cette à cette idée là justement pour
accompagner y compris les professionnels
mais on n'est pas effectivement au stade
on accompagnera à l'achat des véhicules
électriques six véhicules étaient des
voitures sa part air en termes
budgétaires relativement important
comment on a promis de finir cette
séance à l'heure on va faire un mot de
conclusion je vous demanderai une minute
chacun en commençant peut-être par vous
david kimelfeld si vous avez un mot à
rajouter et on terminera ici pris
suffisamment la parole je crois que le
message que moi je souhaite faire passer
c'est que c'est encore une fois ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est que cette
affaire d'énergie de consommation
d'énergie de coûts de l'énergie passe
aussi par un certain nombre sans avoir
la prétention de régler bien évidemment
avec des mesures locales une situation
mondiale telle qu'elle est évoquée ici
mais je pense que le changement des
pratiques les mesures qui peuvent être
prises sur les territoires et j'en ai
donné quelques exemples contribué je
pense que si l'ensemble des territoires
et l'ensemble des grandes métropoles
dans le monde
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a des grandes
métropoles dans le monde
prenez un certain nombre de mesures on
règlerait en tout cas certain nombre de
problèmes sans attendre de grands débats
autour du coût de l'énergie mais je
pense qu'on arriverait à régler et
amener quelques réponses pour notre pour
un monde un peu plus équilibré oui moi
je suis intervenu un petit peu de marge
sur les questions de politique
climatique global à votre conclusion est
suivi sur lequel je m'intéresse en ce
qui concerne ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui je
ne peux que répéter ce que j'ai dit dans
mon introduction à savoir que toute
chose qui va dans la direction d'une
annonce du prix du carbone même si c'est
un prix réel avec toutes les difficultés
que cela comporte
mais bon ça pourrait se faire par
exemple au niveau européen on l'a dit
tout à l'heure vous qu'il s'agisse d'un
prix virtuel qu'on n'utilise dans le
calcul économique permet de désenclaver
trail eddy merckx dans des dimensions de
l'intervention lorsque vous faites des
voitures qui consomment moins d'essence
il y avait plusieurs objectifs vous avez
un objectif de diminuer la pollution
urbaine
l'objectif de diminuer les émissions de
gaz carbonique et qui est un objectif de
la politique climatique est de même
lorsque vous faites des dents dans
d'autres domaines
quand vous faites de la d'efficacité
énergétique vous faites également de la
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
parce que les gens prennent pas les
bonnes décisions sur la base du système
de prix et des choses qui sont liées à
la politique climatique
tout donne lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on a pas
de signal de 2 signale le prix de toutes
les choses cliente tient compte on
risque d'avoir des politiques nombreuses
multiples mais incohérente
merci jean marc jancovici votre
conclusion
et puisqu'on est aux journées de
l'économie
j'en parlais un tout petit peu je vais
rappeler juste une chose on aurait pu
commencer par ça tout à l'heure c'est
rappeler la définition de l'énergie on a
beaucoup parlé de l'énergie pendant ce
débat comme si c'était une chose qu'on
achète et une chose qu'on utilise en
fait c'est pas salé énergie l'énergie
avant tout c'est une grandeur physique
et c'est une grandeur physique qui
caractérise le changement c'est à ça que
ça sert
les physiciens se servent de l'énergie
pour caractériser le changement d'état
d'un système donc l'énergie c'est le
changement est ce que l'économiste
compte avec des euros c'est-à-dire un
empilement de valeur ajoutée le
physicien peut très bien le comté en
joules c'est à dire une succession de
transformation c'est la raison pour
laquelle une des choses qui a été dit
tout à l'heure par patrick c'est que
plus d'énergie c'est plus d'économies
mais parce que c'est très exactement le
même processus que vous mesurez avec
deux unités différentes et donc vouloir
plus d'économies avec moins d'énergie
on n'est pas très loin de se rapprocher
de la quadrature du cercle ben c'est
très exactement ça qu'on veut quand on
commence à parler d'énergie propre on
n'est pas très loin de vouloir rendre un
cercle carré donc on est arrivé à
l'heure des choix
voilà c'est ça que voulez vous dire on
est arrivé à l'heure des choix à un
moment il va falloir qu'on se mette
d'accord avec nous mêmes et qu'on se
dise
est-ce que ce qui compte d'abord c'est
de rester sur une planète qui va pouvoir
supporter et qui est gratuite dans
l'économie je vous rappelle que les
ressources naturelles sont à zéro tant
qu'il n'y a pas touché 1
c'est monsieur c'est ses copains qui ont
dit ça donc la planète tant qu'on n'y a
pas touché elle est à zéro dans nos
comptes
donc c'est évident que son amortissement
on s'en fout complètement
donc il va quand même falloir qu'on se
mette d'accord avec nous mêmes
aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'on est arrivé
sur est ce qu'on veut la durée auquel
cas on aura la contraction économique ou
est ce qu'on veut la fête économique
tant que ça passe
à ce moment on n'aura pas la durée et on
est vraiment aujourd'hui à l'heure des
choix et c'est le débat sur l'énergie
qui permet de comprendre qu' on est
arrivé à l'heure de ce choix je vais
finir juste aussi en disant que je vais
arriver maintenant un âge où je peux
sortir des sentences de vieux cons vous
vous rappelez pour les plus jeunes dans
cette salle qui sont nombreux et tant
mieux que un de vos profs vous a
sûrement déjà raconté qu'on savait pas
bien résoudre un problème qui était
posée de travers en ce qui concerne
l'énergie malheureusement le plus
souvent le problème est posé de travers
donc prenez le temps de vous documenter
et là dessus je vais terminer pour
comprendre comment le problème se pose
ça sera pas du temps de perdu
[Musique]
deux remarques d'économistes aussi mais
qui partent par la direction qui sont
ceux qui poussent pas sans doute un peu
de pessimisme aussi première remarque ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est le retour
au nationalisme économique
les américains taxent les importations
les chinois rendent la vie difficile aux
entreprises étrangères
l'un d'eux patrick le disait aussi et ce
nationalisme économique il est quand
même extrêmement incompatible avec le
traitement d'une externalités mondiale
qui est le climat vue d'un pays où d'une
région le problème climatique n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance et ses émissions
propres de co2 n'ont pas d'effet négatif
particulièrement sur son économie
donc j'ai du mal à imaginer qu'on arrive
à une solution globale dans un
environnement où ce nationalisme
économique est en train de monter
deuxième remarque nous vivons depuis
vingt ans de plus en plus avec une
exigence de rentabilité du capital qui
est beaucoup plus élevé que ce qui est
normalement le cas aujourd'hui
l'exigence mondial de rentabilité du
capital allait en 12 et 15% par an chez
total
ça viendra et et est donc et donc on
voit qu'on le calcul privé économique ne
va pas permettre de traiter le problème
de climat parce que comme le disait
patrick ce point de climat c'est pas un
problème a actualisé à tous pour cent le
règne de climat il n'existe pas et donc
le niveau d'intervention publique qui va
falloir pour forcer les agents privés à
passer par dessus une exigence de
rentabilité à toulouse 15 % il est
absolument considérable et c'est
sûrement pas seulement 30 euros la tonne
pour le co2 c'est une intervention
publique beaucoup plus forte que ça qui
va t ses serres merci
[Applaudissements]
il y avait un vrai polytechnicien sur
cette pièce cette scène c'était lui les
autres simplement tu vas parfaitement
poser problème mais franchement
aujourd'hui le vrai débat c'est que la
réponse à la question que tu poses est
totalement divergentes entre les pays
émergents et les pays développés et moi
je suis de plus en plus frappée sur ce
sujet pour voyager sur cette planète
chaque fois que je reviens on ne parle
pas du tout de la même façon ici en
europe ocde développés et dans les pays
émergents et les pays émergents ils sont
plus nombreux nous faudrait quand même
pas l'oublier quand on parle de ce débat
deuxième commentaire que je veux faire
il appelle à une formule qui est
intéressante a dit finalement c'est une
question de savoir si les réconcilier du
citoyen et le consommateur mais moi je
voulais être sûr que les citoyens ont
fait comme si il est évident qu'ils
adhèrent à cette politique que tu viens
d'écrire de moins de croissance etc
ça me paraît pas du tout évident d'abord
parce que le débat est extrêmement
complexe et que malheureusement sur ce
sujet là alors c'est un sujet très
fondamental et je suis frappée du fait
qu'il est traité à l'emporte-pièce avec
des formules tu as 10 350 fois on dit
que vécut battu réglé donc il va tout
régler
il ne leur a rien du tout je veux dire
pour être maintenant on a acheté une
société de batteries lithium-ion c'est
super compliqué et le jour on se posera
la question de recyclage des batteries
lithium ion
mais on va avoir un énorme problème
cette planète donc je trouve qu'on a un
manichéisme sur ce sujet qui empêche
d'avoir le vrai débat et qui empêchèrent
les citoyens de se prononcer vraiment
donc croire que les citoyens se sont
prononcés en faveur d'une d'une écologie
à long terme c'est pas du tout évident
est d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que quand
on parle encore une fois du consommateur
alors lu par le comble il réagit tout de
suite il n'y a pas de doute il est
contre la hausse des prix de l'énergie
je peux vous dire et c'est vrai y
compris chez nous ici et donc c'est
assez compliqué d'expliquer à des pays
en développement que ce que on veut pas
faire chez nous est bon parce qu'ils
nous écoutent troisième message
d'optimisme c'est la technologie
je suis depuis 20 ans dans ce monde les
nerfs
j et franchement le monde d'aujourd'hui
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'ils étaient
il ya vingt ans et des choses dont on ne
parlait pas on n'imaginait même pas il
ya 20 ans où il ya dix ans donc il faut
croire et c'est une vraie difficulté que
de se projeter à 2040 2050
parce que on fait de la prospective avec
l'état des techniques qu'on a et c'est
très compliqué mais franchement il ya 20
ans on parlait pas des eaux liant par
les panneaux solaires on parlait pas de
lithium ion même ya trois ans et à 3 ans
est ce que vous croyez que les
constructeurs automobiles vous parlez
que leur véhicule serait électrique non
c'est pas vrai donc le monde bouge très
très très vite et ça ça me rend très
optimiste malgré ce qu'on a dit parce
que je crois que à un moment alors
simplement il faut continuer à faire des
efforts les technologies émergeront et
il ya des acteurs et là il faut pas
s'attendre seulement que les états et
les politiques publiques faut que les
acteurs que nos représentants les
acteurs privés eh ben on se prennent par
la main nous mêmes et vous savez quand
une entreprise comme total tient le
discours consistant à dire mais moi j'ai
investi dans une ère où la plus près à
distribuer sur le réseau social sont
servis des recharges électriques mais du
juge et du gaz vers du gaz naturel
véhicule
c'était impossible ya cinq ans parce
qu'il ya cinq ans mes patrons des
stations service qui voulaient du
pétrole point la ligne donc les
mentalités bougent et c'est assez
important et si les mentalités bougent
faut être optimiste parce que derrière
les technologies suivront et on mettra
les investissements sur ce qu'il faut
alors peut-être pas assez vite pour
empêcher d'être à deux degrés 5
mais restons restons tous positifs
optimistes parce que sinon sinon y'a
plus qu'à fermer le dossier
merci
parce que je trouve intéressant dans ce
débat on l'a vu tout du long c'est que
il ya au delà des différences d'anglet
point de vue on voit bien qu'il ya
énormément de sujets qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas encore surmontée et de sujets
de technologique en particulier de
sujets d'économicité aussi maintenant
mois à tord ou à raison ce que je pense
c'est que il ya un mouvement qui était
parti qui est absolument irréversible et
qui est de l'ordre du changement de
perception du land de lors du changement
d'aspiration on appelle ça comme on veut
qui d'ailleurs mon point du touche pas
seulement l'énergie regarder le chemin
le changement qui empruntent s'opérer
dans la façon de consommer les biens de
consommation alimentaires par exemple
comme ça je pense que c'est un peu le
c'est un peu la même là même la même
tendance est la raison pour laquelle
mais ensuite chacun joue avec ses cartes
évidemment un
mais nous nous avons fait ce ce choix de
nous de nous profiler d'une manière de
manière à accompagner ce mouvement jouer
un peu un rôle d'ouvreur alors sans
prendre de risques inconsidérés et on a
la chance d'avoir un socle d'activités
qui est très solide
on peut se permettre on peut se
permettre ça moi je pense que le rôle
des pouvoirs publics s'est aligné les
règles du jeu je vais vous donner un
exemple
au delà même du co2 qui est qui est un
exemple excellent au sim et on a
suffisamment parlé je crois et qu'il
faut mettre en place évidemment là en
tant que groupe industriel
nous sommes en permanence nous
confronter à des injonctions paradoxales
mais massive c'est à dire que à la fois
on nous dit préparer le long terme un v6
t1 investissez dans la technologie et
dans la longueur de conférence aux états
unis gtia il ya quatre semaines
la conférence bloomberg c'était le thème
majeur et toute la planète économique et
toute la planète des financiers étaient
là pour le dire puisqu'il n'en reste pas
moins que quand vous présentez vos
résultats au trimestre ce qui est ce qui
nous arrive donc par définition assez
souvent on vous challenge quand même sur
les résultats de 10 paires court terme
nos donc il faut arriver à jongler avec
le on n'a pas le choix on doit être à la
fois ans
en préparation du long terme et pour
autant tout à fait au rendez vous des
performances de court terme parce que
parce que c'est c'est la loi du genre
voilà j'espère qu'à un moment donné et
on y arrive c'est héroïque de la part de
nos équipes d'ailleurs on arrive avant
nous 20% de nos activités nous et 10 15
milliards tout à l'heure c'est près 20%
nos activités sont baissés d'un euro
notre notre résultat net
comment on fait eh bien écoutez on a
décidé d'être super performance est à
dire qu on a fait des économies
absolument partout mais ça relève un peu
de l'héroïsme mon message c'est de vous
dire je pense qu'il va falloir à un
moment donné faire un tout petit peu
évoluer les règles du jeu pour que
l'ensemble des groupes
si c'est ce qu'on veut évidemment un
bascule un peu dense est dans cette
logique sans qu'ils aient besoin
forcément d'être héroïque
voilà merci
bonne fin de journée
[Applaudissements]
c'est combien c'est bon
[Musique]
enfin à 12h01